Priyanka Chopra has found her wedding
dress so I guess I'm very excited he
caught up with the actress at a bumble
event in New York City where she opened
up about her love life
and her recent bridal shower this is
such a wonderful new step in my life and
I'm so getting used to it because it's
obviously been a whirlwind but I haven't
seen myself happier and just being in
the whole situation of finding somebody
who can be a partner to you in so many
ways than one is amazing so I guess I'm
very excited and last night because I'm
in New York right now and I'm always
traveling and all my friends just my
friends got together and did this I mean
it was so special like I wouldn't have
been able to do it any other way
Tiffany I love Tiffany he's one of my
favorite brands and I just feel like
that's why it was so appropriate to do
it over there because the actress shared
how Nick Jonas made the first move in
their relationship with this opening
line I actually didn't make the first
move he did the first time was a text
and just saying that you know I think we
should connect and whatever and that's
and how she dabbled in online dating
prior to finding love with the clothes
singer no my eye I was on one for a
little while because it was entertaining
and then it wasn't which is why I know
it was fine I mean listen I'm somebody
who believes that no one is an island
everyone needs connections everyone in
the world needs connections and there's
no need to be apologetic about that and
whatever it takes to find those
connections you know you've got to do
what you got to do and even and that
doesn't necessarily only mean in love it
means in every aspect of your life so
the cool thing about bumble is for
married women or engaged women if you
don't want to be on the dating side you
can actually delete the dating site off
of the app you can just be on bumblebees
and bumble bee FF which is really cool
and I just think that I think that's
that's all I'll be able to do on earth
I think I love what's bamboo stood for
it is about empowering a woman and
giving her the ability to make choices
in her life and I have traveled so much
so many places around the world where I
consider myself so privileged for being
able to have a say in the decisions that
happen in my life whereas a lot of women
around the world don't have that
decisions are made for them their life
choices I mean for them and this Bumble
is a social network for women who want
to network in different kinds of ways
whether that is you know finding a
friend or networking but when it comes
to your career or love it's not just a
dating app anymore it's made by women
for women for everyone and and and we
care about you
we're a platform that and so I think all
of these philosophies that stand behind
Bumble is something that made me very
excited about wanting to invest in it
and taking into parts of the world where
I feel like it would empower a woman to
be able to do whatever she wants with
her life I have always believed in
evolution and I feel like human beings
in general if you don't evolve you're
gonna be left behind in doing different
things I started as an actor I did music
I've done producing and I still do
production and that that's when I
started dabbling in the businesses when
I got into production and I just sort of
like the vibe a lot of it and I felt
like I had an acumen and I really want
to just be in partnership with with
people who I inherently believe in and
even in my tech investments I think it
has to be something that pushes the
envelope in the world you know something
that you know is a clutter breaker
leaves a footprint behind and changes
something and has a spirit and a heart
so I'm a little emotional but I feel
like even in business you can find a
little hard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]